relying on the network i hope
there is no effect
because i hope for
a stable government a credible government that can
give confidence
lassana diarra as gorged hillsides d buying
a rescheduling of the greek debt
is  something completely
conceivable it is clear that the
absolute amount of its debt the state of its
economy the level of unemployment the
difficulties of a significant part of
the population mean that this is a
very singular case and I  do not think that
from the Greek case now we can
say that we will extrapolate it tomorrow to
Portugal or Spain or another country
the situations are not comparable
and on tourism seems as much
what the cinema in doha the
sign at the town hall said to the police
at the stadiums he tells me we are at
the arrival of a political force that has
nothing to do with the little
patronage arrangements that we make  experienced with both
major parties fear the first
rai  its that this is good news
second reason it is good news
is that it calls into question many a
priori of the orthodoxy of the
single european thought as they have been
practiced with particular violence
in greece  provides chili